hinduism is often known for its large
and complex pantheon of gods and the
goal of this video is to give an
overview of them and to think about how
they are connected and how they are
perceived
so the hindu trinity as it is often
called is made up of shiva vishnu and
brahma they are often considered to be
the three most important gods in modern
day hinduism shiva and vishnu have far
more
followership i guess you can say or more
people view shiva or vishnu as the
supreme being and there's more temples
dedicated to shiva and vishnu than there
are to brahma
followers of shiva those who view him as
the supreme being they're called shaivas
they're following shaivism or sometimes
referred to as shivaism
shiva has multiple aspects and as we'll
see many of these gods have multiple
aspects and multiple connections but is
often referred to as the destroyer or
the transformer
vishnu as i mentioned also has a
significant following a significant
chunk of hindus are vaishnavas or
followers of
vaishnavism or vishnuism and visnu is
considered the preserver brahma as i
mentioned does not have as much
followership in modern day hinduism but
he is considered to be the creator now
in some narratives he is the creator and
in other narratives he has been created
by either shiva or vishnu now brahma
should not be confused with brahman
that we talk about in previous videos
brahman is considered the absolute
reality the true nature of things and
brahma you could view as an aspect of it
it is one god as part of this true
nature of things in fact everything you
see on this video in fact everything you
see in reality all of these gods to a
hindu could be considered as just
aspects of the true god or the true
reality of brahman
now what's interesting in hinduism
is that
gods are not viewed to have a strict
gender for example vishnu has a female
incarnation and there's also groups of
hindus who view god as taking a
fundamentally female form one group are
known as the followers of shakthism to
shaktism god is female the supreme
goddess and takes many forms
parvati as you see listed here is
referred to as the divine mother she's
viewed as shiva's consort or shiva's
wife but she has other forms like durga
which is viewed as a stronger more
aggressive form of poverty sometimes
referred to as devi or shakthi shakti
means strength or power and is a warrior
goddess you have lakshmi who is the wife
of vishnu who represents or has aspects
of wealth and prosperity you have
saraswathi who has aspects of knowledge
music in the arts and is viewed as the
consort or the wife of brahma now these
are some of the principal deities that
we have on this top row but there's also
many many other significant deities and
as we will see depending on what part of
india you're in and which group subsect
of hinduism you meet they will place
different levels of emphasis on
different deities and have different
traditions and different rituals so
ganesh who is very recognizable because
he has an elephant head
he is often referred to as ganpati
he is viewed as the son of shiva and
parvati and there's a great story about
how he why he has this elephant head and
he is viewed as the god of new
beginnings and the remover of obstacles
and he has a lot of followership and
he's revered in a lot of regions of
western india and that's not the only
places but he's known to be a principal
god in some of these regions durga
similarly that i referred to in eastern
india especially bengal the place where
my family comes from durga puja the puja
for durga the rituals for durga are
considered to be a very important part
of the hindu religion if you go into the
south for some hindus karthikya or also
known as murgan might be a significant
deity that is the god of war visnu is
known to have multiple incarnations that
are very prominent the most prominent of
which are rama vishnu's seventh
incarnation he is the main protagonist
in the ramayana the famous hindu epic
you have krishna who is vishnu's eighth
incarnation and he is a significant
figure throughout hinduism including the
mahabharata and the subset of the
mahabharata which is the bhagavad-gita
now what's really interesting and i
already alluded it to it is you have all
of this diversity in hinduism
someone who worships shiva you might see
at a superficial level seems more
different in their rituals and their
beliefs
from someone who worships vishnu than
say a protestant from a catholic in
christianity or a sunni from a shia in
islam
and what's fascinating about hinduism is
that you don't see these traditional
schisms you don't see a lot of conflict
between the shaivas or the vaisnavas
because to hindus even though you have
this diversity of practice across india
or across the hindu tradition they're
all viewed as aspects of brahman they're
all viewed as different ways to
visualize or to connect with the
fundamental reality or the fundamental
god
and because hinduism has been able to
merge these very diverse practices these
very diverse rituals and it's believed
this emerged because as hinduism emerged
it took traditions from the indus valley
civilization it took significant
traditions from the indo-aryans it took
significant traditions from the
dravidians instead of saying hey our
different traditions are different
religions they merged over thousands of
years into one religion and the word for
this merging taking an amalgamation of
multiple rituals multiple ideas multiple
multiple practices and turning them into
one is known as syncretism and hinduism
is perhaps the best example of
syncretism where you have these
incredibly diverse practices the gods
that i show here are just a sample of
them but they've been connected through
this overarching very diverse religion
called hinduism and to a hindu they're
all ways of connecting with the
fundamental brahman
and to remind that
we could just zoom out
and we see
the connection with brahman which is
viewed as this fundamental reality which
raises an interesting question
hinduism is oftentimes cited as a
polytheistic religion polytheism you
have multiple gods and clearly i've
cited multiple gods even in this video
and this is a sample of all of the gods
in hinduism but at the same time they
are all perceived by many or most hindus
as to being aspects or ways to connect
with the fundamental reality of brahman
whom many hindus would call to be the
true fundamental god and so based on
that they would say these are just
aspects of the one god and so they would
argue that it is monotheistic so i'll
let you decide how you view it or if it
even matters to apply a label like
monotheism or polytheism to the idea of
hinduism the big picture is
is that you have many gods and many
practices and they are diverse across
the hindu world but they are all viewed
as connected to this notion of brahman